i just want to get your opinion about uh
tall women
[Music]
that's what i'm saying out the gate
yum
onward i myself am 5 10 and my partner
is 5 10 5 11. it doesn't bother me i
mean i used to have like an issue
growing up just like with my own
posture and things like that i mean i'm
definitely more confident now i keep
suga
i take care of my body i stand tall what
have you but i don't know i just want to
get your opinion like
look i'll tell you right now i like a
tall woman
you know i like a you know
a little portable woman too but a tall
woman
well i guess it's i guess it's
it's some men are feel afraid of it
you know some men i think they want to
they consider and be some men will marry
tall women because they also want to
marry a man they consider him gay
and
okay and if you're if i'm but but
they're afraid to either be gay or they
are not gay
and so they just get a tall woman that's
how you know
they say you know maybe i would love to
have a man but i'm not doing it
so i'm just going to get a tall woman
you know and cut her hair short and put
her in jerseys and stuff you'll see a
lot of times
you'll have a dude out there that seems
kind of like you know
like he could you know be for men
and he'll have his wife there and have
her in a damn dennis rodman jersey and
with a damn fade on the side and you're
like damn
he really carved her up you know he
really carved her up
so uh
what are you asking about oh i like a
tall i like a tall bird
you know i like that lady hell yeah that
long
that long lady
i like that run and jump up into that
bitch's arms you know what i'm saying
i like a tall i like it nine feet tall
get that bit way up there i can't even
see her
you know i'm just just
just puss level with her you know what
i'm saying i'm just that's right you
know that'd be fine
i like a long you know hang a damn bird
feeder off her ear i like getting two
earrings damn bird feeders
that [ __ ] up there babysitting warblers
and i'm down here hanging out by them
pockets baby you know what i'm talking
about
so i think that yeah i like a long woman
too
because sometimes uh also if you're if
you go somewhere and you all me need to
meet up in a group like at a concert or
something y'all can meet up
meet up at the tall lady let's meet up
at belinda
at 7 pm meet up at tiffany
i like that
so yeah i like a long woman i like a
long leg sometimes
you know they had a lady had one leg
that came out to one of the shows i
think in texas
and she brought that [ __ ] out and let
me hold it
[ __ ] awesome man almost damn teared
up
you know every time i get a hold of a
damn good orthotic i [ __ ]
i can feel the wells start filling up
inside of me god
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you